[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we've just had
a ton of new information about the next
season of stranger things that makes it
seem like it's going to be the best one
yet
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the upcoming show as well as what
could happen in it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't fully
finished season 3 of stranger things
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into my breakdown of
everything we know so far about stranger
things for okay so it looks like season
4 is currently being worked on by the
duffer brothers and they hinted recently
that it will be the final one for the
show in an interview with vulture roster
first set the following we're thinking
it will be a four season thing and then
out you just have to keep adjusting the
story though I don't know if we can
justify something bad happening to them
once a yeah this contradicts earlier
reports by Entertainment Weekly and the
show could go beyond four seasons
however with almost every actor going
off onto some other projects it seems
unlikely that they will still remain in
the show unless their wages increase to
match their demand
David Harbor who plays hopper also spoke
to TVLine about the importance of bowing
out at the right time and said that he
didn't want the show to end up like The
Walking Dead with there being no end in
sight for the characters so it seems
like it could all be over after this but
what could the next season hold and is
there anything that we can guess will
happen in the upcoming release due to
what we know well while stranger things
tends to release during the month in
which the season is set and the mention
of Christmas at the end of season 3
makes it seem like this could likely be
the time that it happens there's
actually a lot of evidence to support
its release around October season 1 was
released in July season 2 in October and
then season 3 in July to gain so an
October release makes sense
it could be delayed slightly to coincide
with Thanksgiving which too was paid
lips
- in the finale and this makes a lot of
sense going off past release dates
there's also a secret cinema stranger
things press event on the 23rd of
February 2020 that could potentially
also be the launch of some new details
such as the confirmed cast and more I'll
of course keep you updated as we learn
more so make sure you stay locked to the
channel for the information as we have
it but who's returning to the show well
all the kids have been confirmed to
return and whilst we don't have any word
on David Harbor those who stuck around
for the post-credits scene will know
that it looks likely that he's gonna be
around - in addition to this there are
rumors that dr. brenner will be back and
though he apparently died during season
1 his death was never shown on screen so
therefore it's a pretty safe assumption
to make that he's alive as well I've
already done a full video and why I
think dr. brenner is actually in the
cell - you and they'll hopper escape to
the upside down I think he may still be
trapped there he clearly looks at the
tear and eyes of his options and when
the Machine explodes he's nowhere to be
seen on the walkway so yeah nobody no
dead is is that saying I don't know
anyway it is now whilst these theories
could likely come true there's been no
word on Billy's return at all and it
looks highly unlikely that the character
will be making a comeback after he fell
fighting the myplayer Murray - maybe
coming back and eagle-eyed viewers will
know that during the show he mentioned
the phone number that when rang in real
life played an answer machine message
directed at Joyce saying that he'd found
something related to hopper so it's
definitely possible that he and Joyce
will team up on a quest to find hopper
wherever he may be
obviously her moving away at the end of
the season with a family and 11 will
throw a few hurdles in the way but I
think it's a safe assumption to make
that the characters will reunite once
more and 11 will have to rebuild their
powers the duffer brothers did confirm
that the move would remain in effect at
least for a while and said in an
interview with E W comm that season 4
will focus on story lines outside of
Hawking's this too opens up the
possibilities of other countries and a
thing this changeup is much needed to
show just how grand scale of problems
from Hawkins have spread to the rest of
the world
season 4 similar to three looks to be
setting the Russians up once more as the
main villains and the post-credits scene
shows that they are still working away
at opening
and continuing their experiments this
could lead to an army of demagogue wins
to take down the u.s. or something
potentially even worse
either way season 4 shaping up to be
something special and if it is indeed
the final season for the show this
ramping up scale makes a lot of sense
and seems like the perfect way to send
the series off with a bang I'm dying to
see what happens and at the moment this
stance is one of the best series that
Netflix have ever created so if it keeps
the bar high I can see this being one of
the best final seasons of all time if
they do indeed decide not to do any
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
this news and if you're hyped for season
four comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of everything we know so far
about the upcoming Netflix Breaking Bad
movie alchemy know it I go over all of
the news we have for the film and give
my thoughts on it so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and you can follow me on twitter
at definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this well so just wanna let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning and still like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on stranger
things for in the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
Definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you